votre haut parleurs intelligent vous
enregistre sans votre consentement
jusqu'à 19 fois par jour les chercheurs
du collège impérial de londres et de la
northeastern university de boston ont
passé six mois à étudier les anciens
connectée de google amazon d'apple et de
microsoft
malgré les promesses de sécurité et de
respect de la vie privée formulées par
les fabricants les chercheurs ont
découvert que les enceintes des écoutes
plusieurs fois par jour sans avoir été
interpellé souvent parce qu'elle confond
des conversations pour des commandes
vocales
dans ces situations des extraits sonores
d'une durée de 6 à 43 secondes peuvent
être enregistrés
s'il est parfois possible de les effacer
il n'y a aucun moyen de savoir si les
fabricants ont déjà utilisé ces extraits
et de quelle manière
[Musique]